okay so the perp came in through the
window left the mighty red footprint and
apparently had sex with the dish rack
showcasings found here two shots bang
bang great work Detective
get a tie that's mine you took it from
my desk that's right Charles good solve
Ty for you thanks now everyone be sure
to put those on because it's impossible
to solve crimes unless you're wearing a
tie lay off the captain that man is
gonna be my Rabbi okay first of all when
you use the word Rabbi you know that
turns me on and that's unfair in the
work environment secondly your Rabbi is
a pain in my ass hey
where you going to the dance contest I
am nationally recognized Fox Trotter
Dave blathus and these are my proteges
Rhonda Shawarma and Hank Frankel I don't
care who you are upstairs is closed to
the public bye but we didn't have to
endure this crap when we danced in
Barcelona
your dress makes you look like a mermaid
I'll see you in a little bit
the next event will be keep your cover
contestants must craft an undercover
Persona and talk to as many police
officers as you can before being
recognized pregnant nice means you had
sex damn right I did and I forgot my
birth control yeah
I think the belly will draw attention
away from my face smart like one big
boob
Amy Santiago date time time to date
Peralta this outfit is ridiculous Chop
Chop there's plenty of embarrassing to
do in only a few hours to do it in
happy oh yeah you look like every girl
at every bot Mitzvah I ever had a crush
on let's see the bow
just like Jenny gildenhorn
[Music]
that guard by the door will not move oh
just made eye contact with me like cool
dance dance dance you don't have to say
dance every time you make a step good
call hey do you want me to actually show
you how to do this so you don't hurt
yourself and possibly others yes ready
[Music]
foreign
yeah Maybe
I blew it I only got through two people
he's kicking so much you want to feel
hey it's on the side oof I got to six
dumb baby people are right they ruin
everything I want to try let me be
pregnant
adorable right I can't believe I lost
again I was so psyched up for this what
happened well I'm maybe being so psyched
up is what happened like every time
we're doing police work you're always
super smart you stay calm and take your
time but every time we do dumb games
like this you get all frantic and act
like a crazy idiot my advice next time
don't act like a crazy idiot thanks
that's surprisingly insightful yeah well
motherhood really opens a man's eyes I
finally feel as if I'm part of something
bigger than myself all right too much
yeah Peralta
what the hell where were you I got
eliminated excuse me officer yeah
sweetheart sweetheart seriously Hank is
how you talk to women who come in here
Jimmy Jabs I didn't make it past one
person you're out I'm in the finals and
all I have to do to get Katie's number
is beat Amy oh that's nothing hey don't
you dare touch Amy Jr that's right it's
your baby are you saying I knocked you
up you sure did Jake
can I talk to you for a second yeah sure
thing hold that sure all right Jake you
want to call it the bed seriously you're
gonna back out now just because you're
losing what is this a riverboat casino
on the River of No Rules no I'm giving
you a chance to call off the bed because
it's clear you don't actually want
Katie's number because you're still into
Amy what that's crazy I just spent the
whole day fighting for another girl's
number so I spent the whole day flirting
with Amy yeah we're joking around
because we're friends now that I've
moved on then prove it
beat Amy and don't flirt with her at all
fine easy but you better tell Katie to
clear her schedule out Thursday for a
date because I am working nights until
then and the following weekend I am out
of town let's do this and I don't know
how Batman does it it is super scary up
here hey will you grab the binoculars
they're in my Stakeout bag your Stakeout
bag is 98 nuts I get snacky besides nuts
are super healthy they're like zero
percent fat
Jake that's not true at all it's
actually the opposite what that nut
vendor lied to me
I think a pigeon just flew out of your
car yeah the windows don't exactly roll
up the car's a piece of crap why do you
love it so much
you really want to know
I was two days out of the academy super
nervous saw this guy run out of a bodega
clutching a bunch of cash so I pursued
him on foot 11 blocks
finally catch him cuff him throw them up
against that car
turned out there was a for sale sign in
the window and it being the best day of
my life I bought it
thus began the debt crushing debt
you do know me no
only if you throw it ready
nice
ready uh-huh
[Applause]
what are you doing
you're trying to catch it in your nose I
got it I got it I got it all right let's
hope keep practicing okay
Peralta oh good news Peralta I found
someone from the night shift to relieve
you on your Stakeout oh still make Time
Square
um
you know Captain hold off on the relief
team we're already here plus I'm curious
to see what happens okay so cool
how you doing any progress yep watch
the key is volume I see that
Hey Jake question for you when I beat
you which victory dance should I do this
one
or this one
wow okay
both are examples of victory dances no
comeback
here I burned you with those moves
yep
Amy
hey thought I missed you Hey Jake
amazing assignment I have to admit
I'm a little jealous really well if you
want I could help you get fired I'm
really good at it
yeah
this is real this is happening
look um
I don't want to be a jerk I know
you're dating Teddy and it's going
really well it's just
what's going on
I don't know what's going to happen on
this assignment and if something bad
goes down I think I'd be pissed at
myself if I didn't say this
I kind of wish something
could happen between us
romantic styles
and I know it can't because you're with
Teddy and I'm going undercover and
that's just how it is but
anyway we're
not supposed to have any contact so I
should go America needs me
bye
[Music]